but we've had hundreds of thousands of
people now take our online courses I
think that you comm 101 is approaching a
hundred thousand and so that means that
you can you can explain to people why
free markets work why other markets
don't work by other ways of organizing
yourselves don't work so let me give you
just an idea of how many have ever taken
one of the hills of colleges online
courses okay so you know what they are
is they are archived right now I mean we
have we there's a period where they're
ongoing and we have a new course that's
ongoing right now and and but most of
our courses are really archived so if
you go to look take the econ 101 online
course or to use it in your classroom
you just go and it's it is not live in
the same sense that Margaret course that
Margaret's courses are live we don't get
feedback immediately to ourselves from
students nor do we get we try to reach
them individually the way our course
worked is the there's a discussion board
I in fact here's I gave I did about a
week of filming and and so each day we
did a different lecture and then John
Miller how many had know John Miller
you know runs our journalism program I
already told you you're not supposed to
follow him on Twitter right supposed to
follow me on Twitter but if you get on
what we do is that we have a discussion
board where students themselves or
whoever's taking the class themselves
can basically quit comments as you would
see on a blog or something and other
students would respond and then what I
did was I took a went the sort of the
the most popular question out there and
I did a three to five minute response
for that and then John Miller would
interview me and we have about a 20
minute discussion about things that are
related to that topic but the course is
also designed to
get your interest to do it if you when
you look at it they're all 35 minute
lectures about but how do I get you to
want to do the 35 minute lecture you
know that's what you know Mises said and
and liberalism you know you have to get
people's interest you have to you know I
have to say things like you know nine
billion people woke up in New York City
today right and there was exactly the
right amount of Starbucks coffee then
there's exactly the right amount of
bagels and there was exactly the right
amount of toilet paper and it happened
in Chicago and it happened in Baltimore
and guess what it's gonna happen
tomorrow
how in the world does that work right
there's nobody in charge every morning
which is a wake up say oh my gosh this
is incredible so you got to do something
like that to get people's attention so
each of these each of the lessons has a
little three-minute teaser to get your
interest to say oh wow that was you know
that is sort of interesting maybe I
don't you know listen to the other
thirty five minutes of this thing so and
and the college is actually put together
all those teasers if you get on YouTube
and do econ 101 and twenty two minutes
what they did is they just took and put
on YouTube the you know the three minute
teasers for each of the each of the
lectures that I did that but again the
course is designed to accomplish the
goal of explaining to people who don't
really have a good understanding of how
free markets work how it is that all
these people woke up and this is exactly
my rant right amount of stuff and
there's nobody in charge because their
intuition is you know our natural
intuition is to say wow somebody should
be in charge right but how can this
create was what Hayek called a
spontaneous order and and so how can you
explain that to people in a very short
period of time and it's given them a
basic understanding so that's that's
what we're trying to do in in this
particular course best jot and I like to
tell this to dr. Arnn cuz he was a
politics professor is
that bass shot in 1850 and the law said
a science of economics must logically
precede a science of politics and and so
what what what he's really saying is
that we have to know how markets work
and how people interacting with each
other work if we are going to decide
what the role of government is if people
interacting with one another causes all
sorts of chaos then we'd have an idea of
why you know that we need a strong
government to do X Y & Z whereas most of
what people does increases the the state
of knowledge and increases our lifestyle
and as is social cooperation then we
have a much lower role role of
government so what this course is aimed
at is for either high school students or
home schoolers or for supplement to
economics classes at the undergraduate
level but I know that some graduate
programs are using it at least in their
MBA programs and so it's really designed
as a supplement it's not designed to be
a course that you would get credit for
towards the you know your university
degree or college degree in fact none of
the courses are designed to do that it's
a very different again that what
Margaret's doing it's very different
because you know she's those your online
courses are doing what they're helping
people advance they're towards their
degree our purpose of our line online
courses is not to give people credit
towards a degree but rather to give
people knowledge and get them interested
in whatever that you know if you maybe
you watch my econ 101 online course and
you and you say wow you know I should go
take a course you know a full course
somewhere in economics or maybe I should
try to send all my kids to Hillsdale
College because they're so cool but but
but it's so again it's it's very
different so as a consequence the
tuition is extremely low right that's
the opportunity cost of your time you
know we all are courses that are that
way they're all free online courses
and as a result we teach it differently
as as you know what I'm there is not to
present something to you and I'm
watching you respond like right right
you know we've all spoken in front of
large audiences how do you do this right
you you you're looking at what people
are doing so you go oh my gosh they
didn't really get that maybe I should
you know do some extra on that or oh wow
they really like that maybe I should you
know expand what I'm doing the way this
works is you're staring into a camera I
mean that you know you're just staring
into a camera there's no one else in the
brothers that you know the the people
that are running the camera but there's
you know four or five people in the room
but you're not looking at them you're
looking at the camera and so it's a very
different way of teaching and and and I
suppose you know I've never taught an
online course like like Merritt has so I
don't really know how that works but I
imagine it's very much the same way that
then you when you're teaching an online
course you don't have this feedback that
you've got going on when you have
students right in front of you for for
our course it was merely a matter of it
was almost like doing a television show
I mean a bird is where did Burke go he's
over there yeah Burt Burt's done a few
of these as well you know and it's it's
like it's like doing a television show
so it's much different than being in
front of in front of a classroom where
it's more like you know a rock concert
right I mean that's why we do this right
so now in the particular class that that
I have is is designed to as I said to
become a supplement to other classes or
to introduce you to the topic and and
and so the first part and you know in my
particular class the first five or six
lessons are pretty much micro oriented
and then the last two lectures that I do
press dr. Arnn does the first and the
and the tenth and I do the eighth in the
middle that's designed the last two are
designed to give people an understanding
of one of them as Keynes economics to
give them an understanding of Keynesian
economics so that they can know why in
the world did President Obama say we
should have a stimulus package or why is
the Federal Reserve trying to lower
interest rates so they it's not
obviously long enough that they can
critique this but at least they can say
oh I understand they must be using
Keynesian economic theory to do that and
then the last the the ninth one the last
one that I do we do to Austrian business
cycle theory to try to say wow there's
another story to this and how many have
seen the what's the rap video hi Chris
Kings yeah so it's sort of meant to do
that
right it's it's sort of meant to meant
meant to provide here's one way of
looking at it here's here's the other
way of looking at it now
one of the things people come up to me
all the time and say oh my gosh I took
your online course alright you know I in
fact I was walking to his Dale I'm
walking along this guy comes up to me I
don't know who he is he says oh you're
Gary Wolfram I said really
how'd you know that he says well I took
your online course so you know that's
one advantage of doing Hillsdale so if
you got hundreds of thousands of people
that that can recognize you and you can
feel like you know you made something
with your life but
one of the more interesting things was I
was you know I was listening to Rush
Limbaugh and a student comes on and
starts talking about he's taking
Hillsdale colleges econ 101 course and
that he was a home schooler and how much
he was I'm glad he said how much he was
enjoying the course but it but he did
and so now I know okay wow there's
outreach out there that we couldn't
otherwise have and whether you're
teaching an online course for credit or
whether you doing it the way Hillsdale
College does it is that you can really
expand the state of knowledge I mean why
or what you know why are you guys here
you know you guys are here to expand the
state of knowledge to to learn how to
talk about the mission of what your
college is or what your university is
and and that this this gives you a much
broader way of doing it and you folks
could do you know a less polished
version Amin the college probably spent
a lot of money bringing in people and
they built a little set for you know so
that I could stand in front of it and
looks like I'm in a classroom and you
know they brought in TV crew and makeup
and all that stuff which was which was
very fun actually like I said it makes
you feel like you're a TV star but
anyway but so but you could do a much
you know much less polished version of
that by just saying hey why don't I put
together some some basic lessons that
can supplement when I'm teaching in
class because all my students in my econ
105 it's called introduction political
economy class I tell them you know you
didn't understand you know you should go
look at the at the lesson on profit
maybe you didn't quite get it but you
can play it over and over again
where's you can't do that in a regular
classroom so so it can be used as a
supplement that way but you could do
your own and just you know I don't know
how to do it but I'm sure my freshman
and college kid can do that is to put it
up on on YouTube you know I know enough
to know that all you got to do is have a
computer with a little thing on it
that's got a camera all right and
somehow you can magically turn that into
your own online course and I guess
that's what what I think might be useful
to you is you know you well maybe you
want to do something that that you know
you know you have student you know
elasticity kids always have trouble with
elasticity of demand and in fact just as
an aside and probably using at home
anytime but as an aside you know I have
a I have a true/false question that I
say and a if a good is inelastic and
demand it means people will buy the same
amount no matter what the price okay and
I tell them okay that's not right you
know that says the last thing zero but
if it's less than 1 its inelastic and I
tell them you know I'm gonna put this on
the midterm don't get it don't don't put
true if the answer is gonna be false
even if you don't understand it guess
what I get about 25 percent of them that
put true okay so when I'm but so what
I'm thinking is that if you know if I
just did some sort of online section
they could watch it oh you know again
I'm so I think that it doesn't have to
be online in you know a massive open
online course but it could be online
just for you or for your students or for
you know I'm putting it put it up on
YouTube and that's how to Justin Bieber
get here all right put it up on YouTube
uh sure sees it now he's a
multi-millionaire
so maybe put it up on YouTube and see
what happens so again I'd like to you
know I just like to encourage you folks
to go out and you know experiment that's
what online courses is all about right
it's about experimenting and a new
technology will just you know do it on
your own